hello
and welcome we're excited to have you
join us today where we'll be sharing
some exciting ideas around enhancing
collaboration
with sheetz python and google cloud
i'm andy rudd a product manager with g
suite currently focused on google sheets
i'm joined today by my colleague annel
who is also a product manager
working on google cloud platform anil
and i and our teams have been thinking a
lot about
analytical collaboration and for many
reasons collaboration is
more important now than it's ever been
sometimes though
and in particular when it comes to
complex analysis
today's solutions can be a bit tedious
often this is because the tools that we
use and prefer
very significantly from job role to job
role
we've been working towards more of an
ideal solution
and we're excited to give you a sneak
peek of that today
from our point of view an ideal solution
would do a few things
it would allow anyone in an organization
to be self-service
to be able to do the analysis they need
to do regardless of their technical
proficiency
it would allow common analytical tasks
and workflows
uh that a company uses internally to be
standardized
and it might even allow the most novice
of spreadsheet users to leverage
powerful open source libraries and cloud
infrastructure to get stuff done
so with that said the solution that
we'll show off today would allow you to
expose python based custom functions in
google sheets
these custom functions are powered by
gcp serverless platform product cloud
run with the serverless model
users would not have to deal with
managing infrastructure and they would
only pay
when their functions are run so with
that said
today we're going to go through a few
things what happens now
we'll cover a common analytical uh
frustration that we hear about in
companies all around the world
we'll talk about what could happen
we'll show you a demo of that tool
actually in use
and then we'll give you a sneak peek
under the hood uh in the form of an
architectural overview of what we've
built so far
and then we'll give you some tips for
staying in the loop uh
to learn about what we're up to as we
continue to develop this
product further so what happens today
let's take a look uh at how
collaborative collaboration happens
in companies all around the world today
let's enter an alternate universe if
you'll allow us
where anil and i are still colleagues
but this time we work at a company
called
alto strut alto strat is a packaged
foods company that specializes
in sweet snacks in particular andy is a
business analyst there
and he is often responsible for
aggregating key business metrics
uh delivering presentations to
leadership to give the latest updates on
kpis
anil is a data scientist he has a
background in statistics
and he is most comfortable happiest when
he is programming in python
they have worked on some projects over
the years but they do not know each
other that well
it's often been more of a give than a
take with andy firing off last-minute
requests for some late-breaking analysis
that leadership has asked for
they're both comfortable with g suite
communication tools
uh chat and email but andy is more
comfortable
in a spreadsheet he's he's familiar with
the traditional productivity suite of
tools
nil is familiar with cloud
infrastructure he likes to
program in ide the the code editor of
his choice
um and one more thing lately alter strat
has been thinking about how they could
reevaluate their existing suppliers of
two key ingredients sugar and flour
unsurprising based on what they're known
for
and how they might consider other
suppliers in order to keep their costs
down
and maybe also be more flexible in
responding to demand planning exercises
that come up in the future
so let's go inside a recent friday
morning when
andy and the nils pass crossed
this will all start when ellen who
manages the business analysis unit at
ultra strat is thinking about what needs
to be prepared
for an upcoming leadership review so
let's say
uh the next monday that's one business
day away there is a q3 wrap up report
that's being delivered to ultra strat's
executive leadership
ellen and andy have talked about offline
some of the things that might go into
that report
and they've determined that he should be
responsible for a few things
summarizing last quarter sales that's
sort of always implicit in this report
but also doing analysis around this
discussion about uh
supplier analysis so looking at the
suppliers that exist now
looking at other suppliers in the market
which ellen and andy have collected some
data on
and then looking at how the various
output and price of those two key
ingredients
could affect ultra shroud's bottom line
there's many downstream implications of
this decision
it will go into their overall production
capacity planning
it will help them have better revenue
estimates and it may even feed into
their price modeling for their products
in the future
so ellen kicks us off with an email she
says andy
on monday we've got this presentation
let's let's make sure that we deliver
that supplier analysis we talked about
i'd like you to reach out to the data
science team
uh and get that modeled andy says of
course
i'm on it so it looks like he's going to
take some of the inputs they've
collected
work with the data science team to
revise a model that maybe they've done
in the past
and then update it with new supplier
capacity information
so andy knows who to go for who to go to
when he has a question like this
he reaches out to a nil and he says hey
it is that time again
lucky you uh can we please remodel
altasha's output
given some of the new information on
suppliers that we've collected
uh and elsa sure of course i think i
sort of remember us doing something
similar to this
a quarter or a few quarters ago let me
try to find that model that i developed
and we'll run it with the new inputs
that you have attached
so maybe anil is not expecting this
request today but he's going to make
time for it
he'll have to find this model that he's
written in the past and
update it with new information
before he digs in though he's gonna
check in with his team uh to baseline on
other requests that they have
on their play today so greta is another
data scientist at alto strat
and no messages her and uh he says a
little
uh gloomily hey another request just
came in from the business analysis team
another one she says what are they
looking for this time
uh anil says product optimization
optimization with new suppliers
greta remembers anil walking her through
this model in the past
uh and she says hey you know what let me
take on the fp
a request that we also have going on our
plates today
and you enjoy this one take it on
yourself uh
i know is a little frustrated here maybe
but uh
we know there's a lot on his plate uh
but he's gonna get the job done
so first things first um
nell starts to look in his his local
computer to determine
when he did this analysis previously um
he's got to track it down
it's always a little bit tedious he has
to think about when the last
time a question or request like this
came in
what he named the model what he named
the file including the python code when
he last
developed this it's always not quite as
seamless as it should be
so that's fine and well but uh
unfortunately
a little while later andy realizes he
left out some key inputs
uh this time to get nils attention more
quickly he sends a chat he says hey
uh i forgot one more thing anil's
starting to respond
uh the frustration is mounting let's see
what this is all about
and he says hey i left out our current
supplier what a stupid silly mistake
uh and so i've just passed along updated
capacity information to you
and anil says of course hey that's fine
no worries i'll be sure to include those
as well
so what does this mean uh and nil still
has a few morning meetings to get
through
but once he gets back to the model uh
he'll turn his attention
in his request he'll think about
combining the now two
disparate inputs that have been provided
uh and then
providing his results back to andy in
some fashion
so andy has asked for a few things
before um but anil has now found the
model that we care about this time
around
what do we want to do we want to
determine ultra strat's potential
product output
given a number of different suppliers
with different information
that can provide key ingredients in
different quantities and prices
we get a sneak peek here of the model
that anil has developed
it looks pretty cool there's some
awesome things happening uh he's using
some popular python libraries like
scipy and numpy to do this optimization
anil is working in the local code editor
of his choice
he might tweak some of the logic as he
goes to make improvements that are easy
he'll swap in the new inputs that have
been provided by andy
and then unfortunately andy is very
scared very intimidated by any sign of
code whatsoever
so he can't just share his python
notebook but what he'll do instead
is once he's happy with the results that
have been generated he'll output a csv
file that can be more easily consumed
with that done anil will turn to google
sheets
which is a well understood tool medium
often used at ultra strat an innovator
of collaborative productivity
sheets is known as a great way to share
an analysis throughout the company
so a while later anil is happy with his
results he imports that csv we talked
about into google sheets
and he shares it away
he wants to give andy an update so he
sends a message he says hey
i just shared you a spreadsheet with the
results some time passes but andy says
oh thank you so much
we're well on our way uh is there
anything interesting
and and here are nell saying you know
that's really where your expertise comes
in you tell me
we've generated some cool business
insights what i care about is i made my
model a little bit better
along the way um andy doesn't have time
to look right now
but based on his work with anil in the
past he trusts that the outputs here
are sound
so uh a few hours have passed andy's
been a bit distracted
but results in hand he shares the output
with l he fires off an email
hey the data scientist team turned
around that analysis we asked for
optimization is herein i have linked to
you a google sheet
containing the results what do you think
ellen says
that looks good but uh you know what
i've been thinking about this and
often in the past our our executive team
has
asked some questions on the fly they've
wanted to know maybe
what if we got our suppliers to reduce
their proposed prices by 10
let's plan for that scenario as well
that's a reasonable
request um but it's gonna shift andy
into a different gear
it's getting late um remember the aim
was to wrap up this analysis by the end
of the day
so uh rapidly he he writes another email
to a mill
you know i hate to do this on a friday
afternoon we've all gotten this message
um but i need a minor tweak can we rerun
that model
assuming a 10 price reduction
hearing nothing he he chats a nil a few
minutes later he says hey i just wanted
to check did you see my email
still nothing another ping uh hey is
that something that we could reasonably
get done by the end of the day
and then in a last ditch attempt it's
almost five o'clock
says hey anil are you even still around
unfortunately
it seems like anil has taken off he
thought he got the job done
he's off to the beach for an early
weekend right so
what happened here some really good
things occurred along the way
there's amazing tools sheets was clutch
in this workflow to share analysis
quickly
uh the communication was pretty clear
anil was comfortable
in the programming tools of his choice
we had incredible domain experts
everyone knew at each step exactly what
they were looking for
uh and you know we knew that we were
asking and answering the right business
questions along the way
and the analysis that actually got
generated was pretty cool right we're
leveraging some
awesome open source libraries to
generate results specific to our company
but there were some speed bumps um the
fact that
individuals along the way were using
different tool kits made things may be a
little bit more arduous than they needed
to be
there were resource constraints it's
clear that data scientists at alto strat
have a lot of inbound requests and
maybe not enough folks to answer them
and andy was
certainly not self-service as far as
this scenario played out
i think maybe you know some of these
pain points in particular have been even
exacerbated over the last few months
when so many of us
have been working from home um maybe
you've been feeling that in your
organization as well
so what could happen uh we think that
there is a better way
and we think that that path could start
in google sheets um
why we saw in this scenario that sheets
is approachable for most folks within a
company
it's universal it is collaborative and
it's very easy to share
quick results and get feedback so what
if instead though
andy had been able to tap into the power
of
python some of the libraries that anil
used that we had talked about
what if he could have accessed the
standardized
optimization calculation that ultra shot
runs
by himself and what if he could have
easily leveraged
cloud infrastructure to get really
powerful big
data results really quickly let's
revisit that scenario with
some of these new possibilities in mind
so just like last time this all starts
on a friday morning when
ellen sends her request she says hey
we've got this monday review coming up
with the executives
let's turn around that supplier analysis
that we had talked about
andy again says sounds good to me
you know this time around though he
might be able to manage some of this
complex analysis
by himself so imagine that in this world
the data scientist team at altastrat has
developed some
ultra specific custom functions that are
written in python
and then made available to many folks in
the company through
google sheets andy might start by
creating a new spreadsheet
he might drop in the raw data from the
various suppliers that he and ellen have
collected information on
and then he might type ahead in a cell
as he would with any
native sheets function to see what sort
of analysis
he could do so here it looks like
ultra strat has named their custom
functions really well we have this well
named spaced format that they're using
to indicate what sort of analysis they
can do
there are some cool things available we
see maybe a revenue forecast custom
function that is standardized and
available
we see a supply a demand forecasting
function et cetera et cetera
so andy will browse this list he'll look
for the sort of custom analysis that he
knows he needs to do
and he'll call it so here uh he found
one called ultra
optimize optimize production he will
pass through that raw data that he
dumped in as arguments into that
function and he will hit enter
just like that he now has results in the
sheet that are doing this
sort of complex optimization based on
the raw inputs that we have on the
various suppliers we're analyzing
so he got this done pretty quickly if we
look at our time stamps this time around
uh we've turned this around in the
course of half an hour
uh and so he shares the spreadsheet that
he's created with ellen he says hey
i ran our optimization model uh we
looked at all of our candidate suppliers
and here are some of the
the initial outputs in the sheet what do
you think
so um the iterative cycle of noodling is
much faster
this time around ellen uh likewise says
hey this looks pretty good
um but you know we've gotten a lot of
questions in the past about
you know what if we can push these guys
on their prices a little bit better i
want to be prepared for those
let's rerun this with that 10 price
reduction
so this time around andy simply goes
back to his spreadsheet where he'd done
that initial analysis
he tweaked some of the underlying raw
data to reflect a 10
price reduction across the suppliers
that we're looking at
and then he calls that python based
custom function once again in sheets to
reflect the modified
outputs so he's in a new column he calls
our function
he enters the function and voila in a
new column he's done
this scenario analysis with a 10
reduction in mind
he comes back to his boss and he says
hey um
he's excited right he's done he's
self-service this time around he shares
his results with ellen
in the same spreadsheet he says you know
i did this scenario planning really
quickly and you know what even if
the executives want to tweak that 10
figure on the fly on monday
we can do it we can do it in the meeting
it'll be live it'll be great it's pretty
quick
um ellen's excited she says perfect
sounds like we're ready for anything
so that was a much more efficient flow
this time around
um let's jump to a real demo of the tool
that we've developed and see it in
action
as you've been seeing i've been helping
andy answer his questions from the
business side
let's now take a look at how andy and i
achieve this ideal workflow he just
showed you
we begin by looking at the sheet that
andy and i maintain together
call that production optimization
here we're looking at altostrat's baked
goods division
and what that division does is we have a
series of factories
that can produce donuts and muffins our
goal
is to figure out the optimal number of
packages of donuts and muffins we should
be making in our factory
so that we can maximize revenue based on
each supplier's
supply of our key ingredients in this
case flour and sugar
you can see that andy has already given
me a list of eight different suppliers
with their quantities you can also see
that i've already started to work on
this model
by filling out two of these rows and
providing two of those answers
but i still have a long ways to go so
how did i come up with these answers
well being a data scientist i mostly
work in python
so what i've done is i've built some
python code
that has a trained model that can figure
out
based on these quantities of flour and
sugar what these ideal production
targets should be
along with the revenue we're maximizing
against
let's take a look at that code now i'm
going to switch over to my code editor
and we see my python function here i
call it optimize production
it takes in two parameters the amount of
flour available
the amount of sugar available and what
this code does
is it uses scipy
and numpy to execute a linear
programming technique
that can figure out the optimal
production targets that we need in our
factories let's take a
deeper look at the code now you can see
that we're starting by
fetching some prices and fetching some
material specs
and then we're populating some values
that we need to pass into the linear
programming library
and then we're returning a solution that
we get
if we look at some of the helper
functions you can see that we're
actually getting
prices live from a sales pricing
database which is really cool because
it allows the sales team to go ahead and
update those prices if they need to
and have those changes reflected in our
model anytime
you can also see that our material specs
are being fetched from another table in
a database
this is also great should we change our
recipe for how we
make muffins and donuts well those
changes would be reflected here as well
so great we see that i have some python
code
that's implemented this model and i've
been testing this and i'm feeling pretty
good about it
now what i really want to do is move to
a more self-service model with andy
i'd love to expose this function
directly to andy so he can call it
inside sheets
the way i do that is i begin by creating
a manifest
this manifest describes to sheets how
this very function should be exposed to
andy
um so you can call it from a sheet
directly
this manifest is pretty straightforward
we first define
a namespace which is just a way of
grouping a set of functions
next i define each of the functions i
wish to expose
in this case i have one and it's called
optimize production
i also provide a bunch of helper text
that will help andy and
other callers understand how to invoke
my function
next i describe the arguments as we've
been seeing
my function takes in two parameters the
amount of flour available
and the amount of sugar available and
each of those is a number
finally my function returns a list
we call a range of numbers that
correspond
to the number of donut packages muffin
packages
and the amount of revenue we will
receive if we produce
those quantities so great i have
functioning python code
and i have a manifest that describes how
my code should be exposed
i've got one last step before i can
deploy here i populate a
requirements.txt file
so that i can capture any of the
external dependencies i might have in
this code
in this case i rely on the scipy numpy
packages along with a mysql connector
great now let's take a look at how i
actually expose this function to sheets
to do that i run a tool called sheet cf
sheet cf allows me to deploy
my code and along with the manifest
and have that function be exposed inside
sheets
so i'm going to go ahead and invoke that
here what this code will do
in just under a minute is go ahead and
deploy my python code
into google cloud platform and wire that
up into the sheet
let's turn our attention now to the
sheet and see how that works
you can see on the right hand side i
have a new add-on that's been populated
let's take a look at that i click here
and i see in the right sidebar
my function that i've exposed called
altistrat.optimizeproduction
and you can see here that all of that
helper text i wrote
is showing up and what this tells us is
that we can
cr we can invoke a function called
aldostrat.optimizeproduction
and pass in two arguments the amount of
flour available sugar available
and it will return to us the a tuple of
donuts
muffins and revenue so let's now take a
look at
how i can invoke this custom function
implemented in python inside my sheet
so let's take one of these other
suppliers for which i haven't
worked on yet and let's try invoking my
function so i'm going to go ahead and
invoke this function
just like any of the built-in functions
just by typing the name
so here we'll start by aldestrat and you
can see that i get
some auto-completions so i click this
and it looks like it needs the amount of
flour available
so that's available in this cell
next it needs the amount of sugar
available so let's go in this cell
and i can go ahead and invoke this
function what this is now doing is
calling my python code
running my model and returning a result
you can see here that based on
this quantity of flour and sugar
my model returned these param at these
values
now this is great because i can call it
directly from a sheet
and because i'm in a sheet i can do all
the cool things i typically do in a
sheet
for example i can erase these hard-coded
values
and i can simply drag my formula up
and you can see that it will do the same
computation calling my python code this
time instead
i can also finish answering the rest of
the question that andy has posed for me
by dragging down
and you can see here that we have
populated an entire table of results
you can also imagine that if andy comes
again
and wants to add a new supplier
let's say supplier 9 and that supplier
can produce let's say
600 units of flour and 200 units of
sugar
and you can simply copy down this
formula and have this
invoke the same python code and model to
come up with a new forecast
of production you can see that right
here
because we're in sheets we can also take
advantage of the rest of sheet's
functionality
for instance let's say i wanted to
figure out which supplier
is going to give us the most revenue
well i can merely
ask sheets about that so i can say
supplier with maximum revenue
you can see here that sheets is telling
us that that supplier is going to be
supplier number four
and it optimizes revenue at seventeen
thousand seven hundred fifty dollars
great we've just seen how this workflow
looks
in action let's take a look now behind
the scenes to see how it works
there are two scenarios here one is i as
a developer
wanting to expose these functions to
andy in sheets
let's see how that works i start by
creating my python code locally on my
machine
and i use the tool we've created sheet
cf
to deploy that package into google cloud
well what's really happening behind the
scenes is we are creating a container
image that will get deployed into
google cloud platforms serverless
product
cloud run so we have some source code
on my machine and we have cloud run
which expects a container
so we're going to have to figure out a
way to build a container that's actually
what sheet cf does
first thing it does actually when you
run it is create a container image
using google cloud's managed servers
called cloud build
cloud build takes a description of a set
of tasks
and a formula of how to create a
container image out of some source code
it executes those tasks and stores
those container images into google's
container registry
so this is all automated with the sheet
cf deploy great
so now we've gone from source code to a
container and that container now lives
in the container registry
the next step is to create and a
deployment
in cloud run of that very container so
that's what happens next
when cloudron gets that request it goes
to the container registry
pulls down that container runs it
locally and exposes
an endpoint on the internet
finally we secure that endpoint so only
the g suite infrastructure can invoke it
and we expose an add-on for andy to be
used inside of sheets
so great so that's how it looks like for
me as an author now what's happening
when andy's actually invoking these
functions on his machine
inside of google sheets so that workflow
looks like this
we start with andy using google sheets
and of course since we've already
deployed this endpoint in cloud run
we have that running in gcp
so andy fires up his sheets picks up a
cell
and enters a function invocation in this
case he's calling the optimize
production function
what this does behind the scenes is
sheets knows that this function is
actually implemented by a cloud run
endpoint
it goes ahead and takes that information
converts it into an http request
sends that over to cloud run cloud run
then looks at my container and executes
it
as we saw the source code running in my
container
was a series of python that uses cloud
sql
and cloud storage to gather its results
once my function is done executing it
returns those results in the form of an
http response
sheets then takes that and shares that
with andy
in the form of displaying it inside his
sheet
so you can see here the power of google
cloud platform is masked completely
behind the scenes
and all andy needs to see is sheets but
my code running in google cloud
has been containerized for me
automatically and in doing so i have
access
to a variety of cloudy pis and the full
power of python
so what can you do with this type of
thing well we see several key use cases
the first is the one we've been talking
about which is collaborating across
teams and roles andy's on business side
i'm a data scientist
sure we used to use sheets already but i
was really copying and pasting results
or maybe loading up a csv occasionally
now in this new workflow we can actually
collaborate
in a self-service fashion
the next is exposing proprietary
calculations
how many times have we all seen
situations where we take a spreadsheet
with some calculations
we make a copy of it to tweak some of
those calculations
and all of a sudden we lose our single
record of truth
imagine this happening throughout your
enterprise imagine how many variations
of some basic calculation are now
running around in your organization
well with this kind of model where you
centralize
the functions inside of a python module
and expose that
through these add-ons the business can
continue maintaining
the integrity of those calculations
and update them whenever they're needed
what ends up happening is the business
will always pick up the latest and
greatest results
and there's no worry about spreadsheet
drift
another is accessing multiple custom
data sources
we already saw this with my python code
which was using cloud storage
as well as cloud sql you might have
custom other
data sources it might be on github or
other locations
and because we're running in a
containerized environment with cloud run
you have access to all of them
another is calling cloud apis because
most google cloud apis have a robust
client library
it becomes very very easy to consume
them from my python code
and the fact that i can marry the
results of that into sheets
makes this a very very compelling
situation for example
i might use google cloud's translate
apis
or machine learning apis to auto train a
model and all of a sudden i can stitch
those together and expose them to the
business
in the form of a spreadsheet and finally
python is what's powering all of this
under the hood
python as you might be aware is full of
hundreds of
great complex packages that make sure
that you do not have to start from
scratch
in fact i use numpy and scipy to do a
linear programming
uh system inside of my code it was very
easy to do in under 100 lines of code
so great what have we seen today so far
we've seen that
in today's world collaborating across
the business
across experts throughout your
organization is a challenge
and cheats already plays a key role the
opportunity we see
is for sheets to play an even greater
role and for the business
to be able to expose functions to the
rest of the organization
through some standardized interfaces and
what that means is folks like andy
can self-service those calculations
and i can spend more time focusing on my
nights and weekends
we're excited about this approach and we
welcome you to
learn more about it and try it out for
yourself you can do so by signing up on
this forum link below
where you'll get notified when this was
made available
we're really excited to hear what you
might do with this
and hear the kinds of scenarios that
might be applicable in your organization
and on behalf of andy we'd like to thank
you for watching this presentation